faire du stade de france dans cars
bondés encore non justement la fff
affirme que les vidéos surveillance ont
été détruites
je suis souple et souple et
souvenez-vous l'événement à vire au
drame faux billets supporters gaz et
charges policières bref c'était une
belle bord c'était le dawa
et la justice ne risque pas d'être rendu
puisque le directeur des relations de la
fédération française de football et à
roanne leprévost a déclaré que les
images de vidéosurveillance ne sont plus
disponibles sont à ces déclarations
sachez que ces images de
vidéosurveillance contenait de nombreux
la chose oui on verra jamais ce qu'elles
ont été détruites pourquoi gilles verdez
ont été détruites parce que c'est les
anglais
au bout d'une semaine au mode une
semaine s'il n'y a pas une réquisition
judiciaire automatiquement les images
sont détruites certain sens plein moi je
m'en réjouis parce qu'on n'a pas le
droit de garder contre l'avis des gens
qui sont filmés par exemple des images
et c'est très bien c'est la protection
de l'individu
sur la vidéosurveillance les images sont
disponibles pendant 7 jours
au bout de sept jours elles sont
automatiquement détruites et la seule
façon c'est qu'on aurait dû avoir une
réquisition pour les fournir aux
différentes populations en revanche que
je peux vous livrer ces deux sentiments
que didier et moi même avons eu en étant
au pc sécurité toute la journée les
images sont extrêmement violentes
réquisitions qui n'a pas eu lieu alors
que la justice a été saisie dès le
samedi soir la justice a été saisie pour
sur la base de l'article 40 sur la foule
à la fosse billetterie
je vais demander l'avis de gilles verdez
c'est absolument normal cyril ces images
elles contiennent des vidéos de gens qui
contrôlent leur avis ont été filmés on
ne peut pas les garder plus c'est la
protection du privé
justice
et
au
total excusez moi j'ai un peu chaud
merci samba
la justice est saisie dès le samedi soir
et ils se doutent bien étant donné le
pataquès que ça fait on s'éteint c'est
une affaire d'état tout le monde en
parle tu vas tu les conserves et tu te
dis ça va évidemment servira comme à
droite les conserver chez illégales
pendant sept jours la justice est saisie
et non ya pas de réquisition judiciaire
mais tu sais bien qu'il bat alva va
survenir cette réquisition puisque
puisque de toute façon la presse s'en
empare c'est un scandale diplomatique on
dirait les anglais en parle mondial
pendant qu'il s'est bien car michel a
été saisie dans la loi valérie benaïm
vous êtes hors la loi dès
sa pâle ce qu'ils ont détruit au bout de
sept jours à qui l'on veut sur ceux qui
n'ont pas demandé avant les sept jours
de les avoir parce qu'ils connaissent la
mèche folle
si j'avais très bon joly s'est jamais eu
non mais c'est vrai que c'est poussif
avait vu cyril que le préfet l'allemagne
et irène vendu au sénat je connaissais
son cousin l'exacte aux métis non je
dirais pas
il a confirmé notre chiffre
il ne ment jamais
fait police je suis le seul responsable
opérationnel de l'ordre et de la
sécurité publique sur l'agglomération
parisienne n'éludant pas mes
responsabilités je regarde ou du moins
j'essaye de regarder avec la plus grande
lucidité
possible ce qui s'est passé autour du
stade de france ce soir là
c'est à l'évidence un échec mais je dois
insister au delà de cet échec sur le
fait que face à une crise d'ampleur dans
un contexte dégradé est difficile nous
avons fait en sorte que le match se
tiennent et surtout surtout qu'il n'y
ait aucun blessé grave et aucun mort je
rentre chez moi
mais je vous le dis les chéris didier
lallement qui veut réagir là-dessus
elle fit
alors
excuse moi tu avoir éveillé
la troisième fois je suis tu mettras
réveille alors respect non mais c'est
délicat comme sujet encore une fois on
voit que au niveau de l'ordre sa part en
sa part en cacahuète c'est dommage parce
que le foot bien voilà c'est
d'agir a dit alors gisement d autant
débuter vous instrumentalise
je te dirai arrêtez moi je crois que ton
mec et instrumentalise qu'il a encore
fait un tweet
alors ça veut dire que je suis soumise à
mon mec ce thème le grand dessein ça
veut dire que moi je suis soumis à gm
préfère être soumis à mon mec gilbert
dès
que je veux dire votre le tweet de votre
votre mec pas de daniel pour les anglais
qui porte plainte c'est pire qu'une
insulte quelle honte les fous furieux
qui disent que c'est de la faute des
anglais vont continuer les fakes news et
personne ne va sauter après un tel
scandale alors il parler bien sûr des
autorités il parle également de gilles
verdez d'hiver les nourrissons elle
intéresse pas vraiment j'ai fermé à 16h
les intéresse pas bah non bah écoutez
batterie métis comme ça fait là bas non
mais bon et aric et deux
arrêtés de prendre mais mon premier fils
de christian laissez moi parler d'un
essai va parler arrêter de tout prendre
au premier degré grâce à mon avenir les
laudes et vous voulez partir en
angleterre cet été
voit les billets regardé pas mal de
temps limité on a même des images
regarder de quelqu'un qui avoue un qui
sait aller regarder une série après
j'espère que j'allais fermer google
suite aux incidents survenus au stade de
france lors de la finale de la
champion's league je tenais à mettre les
choses au clair les jeunes jean f3 n'y
sont pour rien ce sont les anglais oui
vous avez bien entendu ce sont les
anglais ils cette bande georges marc
[Musique]
elle a dit
qu elle a dit merci la reine elizabeth
quinn commercy queen elizabeth
alors
voila merci voulait dire vous mais les
anglais sont responsables de toutes les
quatre le stade de france ne coville
gilles verdez
non qu'est ce que tu veux dire vous
savez comme je suis à la fois tu fais ça
hein on fait ça pour te fais ça pour
parler maintenant
vous savez comme je suis attaché aux
symboles c'est un symbole très important
celui une fois encore démontré qu'en
france on est incapable de maintenir
l'ordre et les seuls défense du préfet
de police ou de darmana et je pense que
damana devrait démissionner c'est de
dire on aurait pu faire mieux mais ya
pas une mort c'est sa seule défense
c'est une catastrophe qui s'est passé
c'était nul n'y avait pas assez de
police les préfets n'a pas su gérer
saint denis n'a pas su gérer les anglais
il faut qu'il ya une démission de là
dessus je pense que si ce n'est pas le
préfet ça je serai bien malin qui est
ému porte désormais la mini des nuls si
la milice des sports allait super l'ado
tout le monde est super chez vous je
vous dis oui aux moyens aériens a qu'un
qui sont pas super il ya qu un seul et
unique responsable en anglais j'ai un
soin minceur j'ai vu avinés était en
train de boire des bières des blondes et
brunes
vous voyez quoi après la fesci et tout
le monde et je le retrouverai soir non
seulement on n'est nullement crème
ananas le mag avec un pays
nos diplomates ici
je suis français et je sais que ce sont
les anglais avec kaka qui étaient là bas
au stade de france et qui va nous dire
qu'à la sécurité c'est écrit dino
mokhtar une fois pour toute et dis la
vérité je peux à vérité et mokhtar dit
la vérité les anglais rodino les anglais
qu'est ce qui s'est passé je suis la
merde et qu'est-ce qui était si on fait
les anglais il en fut la main raconte
nous une anecdote sur les anglais tu
regardes dire a dit mme magne et quand
tu dis ça
peut dire ce qu'elle veut et est pas là
ils ont poussé au porte voix la
qualité là toi tu étais là de fulham et
et attendre
quelques temps tu n'étais pas là et
arrêtées à la panne était chez lui en
train de fouiller j'en attrape et avec
elle celle de pudding ce qu'on nous
avait fait faux bond attraper un avec un
faux billets si la droite part il m'a
fait courir en plus que non
voilà qui après le témoignage de motards
l'affairé close